[Musica]
questa foto potrebbe sembrare un
normalissima persona che corre ma in
realtà racchiude molto di più
si tratta di una disciplina che mi ha
letteralmente cambiato la vita però
andiamo un passo per volta
io vivo da sempre nel mondo dello sport
inizialmente a livello amatoriale con il
judo e la pallavolo nel 1997 ho
conosciuto il tiro con l'arco e in 25
anni di carriera ha ottenuto oltre 600
podi con un titolo italiano assoluto la
medaglia di bronzo al valore atletico
del coni e due esperienze nei gruppi
nazionali però in me non ho mai esordito
in maglia azzurra
dopo un piccolo problema di salute
ho iniziato velocemente a prendere peso
e questo ha provocato non pochi problemi
nella mia autostima nella mia vita
sociale e sportiva
il mio carattere estremamente forte ha
iniziato lentamente accedere e ho
cominciato a sfogarmi sul cibo ottenendo
solamente naturalmente chili in più
tachicardie notturne è una grande
felicità per quei 95 kg che facevano a
pugni con la gioia e la serenità che ho
sempre avuto circondato dai miei affetti
però nella vita succede sempre qualcosa
di improvviso inaspettato che ti può
cambiare la situazione
una sera d'autunno vedo il mio amico
francesco partecipare un quiz televisivo
e parlare della sua attività
il retro running
e disse che
sarebbe andata ai mondiali io l'ho
ascoltato con interesse poi una volta
eliminato è uscito lo studio correndo
all'indietro
mio primo pensiero è stato è impazzito
è un tipo molto eclettico però impazzito
noi la ho sempre conosciuto come un
ottimo astista un saltatore con l'asta
però questa cosa mi incuriosì mi colpì
perché sarà veramente particolare e
ovviamente mi aveva fatto molto ridere
però alla prima occasione gli chiesi
cosa si trattava perché come vedere una
persona che esce da uno studio correndo
all'indietro non lo vedi tutti i giorni
e lui mi disse che non era altro che
appunto la corsa all'indietro un po
quello che è il dorso del nuoto e che
appunto a breve sarebbe andato ai
campionati del mondo
e aggiunse una frase tu alberto sei
talmente pazzo che sono provi te ne
innamori
io lo guardai con gli occhi della
persona sovrappeso che non aveva mai
corso un metro in avanti
figuriamoci all'indietro
e gli dissi assolutamente no sono
impegnato con il tiro con l'arco era in
nazionale italiana in quel periodo
e non se ne parlava e ovviamente era mio
stato d'animo che parlava in questa
scusa c'era un fondo di verità però era
il mio stato d'animo che parlava un
giorno mi alzai dopo l'ennesima bufala
serale e dopo l'ennesima tachicardia
notturna e b il coraggio di guardarmi
allo specchio e dire basta veramente
basta alberto è ora di tornare te stesso
e allora accettai l'ennesimo invito di
francesco che non si era mai dato per
vinto del resto uno che corre
all'indietro può fare qualsiasi cosa
quindi
presi parte una gara aperta anche ai
neofiti
e il giorno della manifestazione
mi presentai mi trovai davanti la
nazionale italiana il retro running
schierata mi fece sentire subito come
uno di famiglia
e allora capii che questo sport così
bizzarro sapeva anche essere molto
accogliente
corsi i 700 metri in programma se c'è
una fatica che non vi dico
sembrava aver corto corso una maratona
40 km comunque e allora totalmente
incapace anche solo di respirare però mi
resi conto che quella disciplina così
particolare poteva essere la soluzione
ai miei problemi
poco dopo
con la il tiro con l'arco e ri nazionale
l'uomo online e decise di studiarmi la
tecnica e mi resi conto di quanti
benefici ad essere training tra i quali
possiamo citare il miglioramento e ritmo
cardiaco il miglioramento
dell'equilibrio della stabilità e la
minor usura di caviglie e ginocchia e
tendini in fase di corsa
migliora i con tanto allenamento e passo
passo la mia situazione psicofisica
tanto da decidere di partecipare sempre
con il buon francesco che senza di lui
non avrei fatto nulla di partecipare
alla mia prima gara in calendario
e fu medaglia d'oro tra la sorpresa
generale figuratevi la mia
e qui arriva nel 2015 l'anno dopo dopo
essermi sposato dopo aver anche superato
un brutto infortunio sono riuscito a
partecipare al mio primo campionato
mondiale a essen in germania
medaglia di bronzo in staffetta due
record italiani
e un indimenticabile finale dei 100
metri individuali
visto questa esplosione dei risultati
allora
mi sentii di condividere questa mia
storia questa mia esperienza di
rinascita con gli altri tramite i social
visto che tanto vanno i social io non le
ho mai amati però mi sono reso conto che
potevo essere di ispirazione alle
persone ed effettivamente i messaggi di
persone in difficoltà cominciarono ad
arrivare
solamente che è arrivato un nuovo enorme
problema questa volta per tutti
nonostante io avessi vinto altre quattro
medaglie ai campionati del mondo di
bologna di questo stato co organizzatore
e ripresi anche il tiro con l'arco come
tecnico di atleti con disabilità però
questo grande problema ha colpito tutti
noi il covip
durante primo lockdown con le posizioni
governative
e ovviamente nessuno poteva fare nulla i
messaggi delle persone che mi chiedevano
aiuto a me come se fossi chissà chi ero
messo esattamente come loro che non
potevamo fare nulla
punto si moltiplicarono e una notte
insonne mi venne improvvisamente un idea
visto che anche io avevo tanta voglia di
muovermi correre sul mio balcone di casa
all'indietro donando una cifra a
progetti di lotta contro la pandemia per
ogni chilometro corso
un po per dimostrare anche che
in una situazione così difficile
si poteva fare sport attivo e
beneficenza attiva
inizialmente pensa di ricorrere 5 km una
distanza fattibile ma spinto
dall'entusiasmo li ho fatti 10 poi sono
diventati 15 e sono arrivato alla
distanza della mezza maratona facendo
anche mio record personale aggiungo e lo
testimoniato in diretta social
questa improvvisa esposizione mediatica
ci ha permesso di versare una cifra
l'ospedale sant'orsola di bologna ea
progetti comunali di assistenza
alimentare
questo è un po la storia della mia
rinascita grazie al ritorno anning uno
sport sottosopra che ha messo sottosopra
la mia vita io sono certo che qualsiasi
difficoltà non si presenterà in futuro e
ce ne saranno
saprò come affrontarla guardando avanti
ma nel mio caso correndo all'indietro
[Applauso]
[Musica]